[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zu sein ist in
diesem video zeige ich euch wieder drei
coole beilagen zum grillen bei lacken
oder je nachdem auch eine hauptspeise
sowie ist eben anrichtet zum einen gibt
es gegrillte tomaten ein richtig
schnelles gegrilltes brot und gegrilltes
kartoffeln ich starte jetzt direkt mit
den gegrillten tomaten
dafür verwende ich acht tomaten etwas
oregano aus meinem garten eine
knoblauchzehe etwas olivenöl salz und
pfeffer im prinzip supereinfach
eigentlich ist es nicht mal so ein
richtiges rezept aber ich dachte mir
kommen wir machen das holz also zeige
ich euch ich habe die tomaten ist ruhe
so sehen sie nämlich ein wunderschön
so sehen sie schon mal perfekt aus
ich nehme ich das olivenöl und
bestreicht sozusagen die oberseite
[Musik]
die sind jetzt schon mal bereit die
rutschen sondern her okay jetzt hier
oregano
da wird fein gehabt
es kommt jetzt hier zum restlichen öl
dazu
schwupps dann noch die knoblauchzehe mit
rein
die braucht ihr nicht fehlen wenn ihr
eine knoblauchpresse benutzt
[Musik]
da bleibt man sich die schale einfach
über und dann nur noch etwas salz und
pfeffer rein und das ist dann schon mal
vorbereitet womit ihr später die tomaten
auch noch so fein und können wenn ihr
wollt ist etwas parmesan schmeckt mit
sicherheit auch sehr sehr lecker dazu
jetzt habe ich hier sozusagen noch das
öl was später drauf kommt und die
tomaten sind jetzt bereits zum grillen
aber nicht bereit ist erstmal noch mein
brot zu geht nämlich alles super schnell
jetzt gibt's noch darf blitz brot und
ich mache normalerweise echt super gerne
magisches vergessen grillen aber blitz
bolt ist super denn ihr müsst nicht
aufgehen lassen da keine hefe verwendet
wird dafür verwende ich 400 gramm mehl
einen esslöffel backpulver einen
teelöffel salz ist habe ich 350 gramm
sahne joghurt 50 gramm olivenöl etwas
oregano und nochmal olivenöl bestreichen
das könnt ihr hier direkt salz und
backpulver vermischen blitz brot weil
blitzschnell alle zutaten hier ein
auch den joghurt das olivenöl und dann
direkt verkneten und ich nehme dann wie
gesagt einfach noch oregano dazu er
könnte kaufhof marie nehmen oder was ihr
treffer noch dazu geben oder einfach
komplett ohne kräuter lassen
im prinzip wie so eine art quark öl teig
noch nicht mit quark sondern mit sahne
joghurt
[Musik]
jetzt ist der teig perfekt und hat jetzt
gesehen die kitchenaid die wackelt ab
und zu drucken hat dabei hefeteig und
kriegt er oft viele nachfragen ob das
normal ist ja ist es normal gibt im
prinzip nahm man muss sich so vorstellen
wenn sie die ganze zur spur stehen würde
und von festen teig unten drin gerade
nudelteig zum beispiel wird jemand
heißlaufen und die gibt einfach nach und
federt das ganze so ein bisschen ab so
die bewegung die jetzt macht und
deswegen also alles völlig normal
doktor innerhalb von einer minute zwei
minuten habt ihr euren teig fertig dann
gebe ich jetzt hier auf einer bemehlten
unterlage
das ist echt ganz geschmeidig und jetzt
kommt es drauf an wie große die brote
haben wollt ich werde jetzt viel mache
ich da raus 88 quote machen also
halbiert vierteln und dann praktisch
noch mal gehen und dann habt ihr schöne
achte
[Musik]
die kugeln formen die müssen jetzt auch
nicht gleichmäßig sein also brot finde
ich darf schon selbst gemacht aussehen
[Musik]
und jetzt hier mit etwas mehl schön dünn
ausrollen zu den fladen entweder
länglich oder hund oder egal welcher
form auch immer
[Musik]
ich muss echt sagen gerade beim grillen
finde ich echt super schön wenn man
alles selber macht und wenn man jetzt
denkt dass so ein brot auch ein paket
echt super einfach geht
also ich finde da kann man sich schon
die mühe machen es lohnt sich auf jeden
fall wenn ich dann selbst gemacht
schmeckt halt einfach doch am besten
das nehme ich einfach dass olivenöl gut
ich hab ich den pinsel der tomaten ist
schlimm mein papa würde sagen es geht
alles unter gleicher ort alles im bauch
jetzt einfach von beiden seiten mit öl
bestreichen und im prinzip ist es so
eine art pfannen brodmann also könnte es
theoretisch auch in einer beschichteten
pfanne anbraten oder wie gesagt auf dem
grill und beim grill da dies dann nicht
direkt auf den grillrost an sondern mit
grin platte zum beispiel dafür was
einfach eine unterlage dass das brot
schön flach auflegt ja und dann wird es
von beiden seiten so ungefähr 23 minuten
angebraten
das war's dann
eigentlich müsste es reichen wenn ich
immer die oberseite bestreichen dann das
nächste auflege
[Musik]
jetzt kommt das dritte grillrezepte
nämlich gegrillte süßkartoffeln dafür
verwende ich ein kilo kartoffeln wir
sind auch bereits gewaschen eine zitrone
oder zwei limetten eine orange etwas
harrys ort so eine scharfe passte
olivenöl salz und pfeffer ich nehme die
sims kartoffel und halbwegs meter länge
nach ich muss sagen ich bin der mega
süßkartoffeln murat ja nicht so wie ihr
vielleicht wisst was hat also da musst
du echt beim halbieren aufpassen dass
euch das messer nicht abrutscht den
westen so einritzen und dann sachs und
wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr jetzt mit
einem kleinen messer bitte hier so eine
art rautenmuster einritzen
zum einen weil es schön ist und zum
anderen läuft dann da später die
marinade rein
[Musik]
die kommen jetzt bei uns auch direkt als
erstes auf den grill denn diese
kartoffeln brauchen am längsten
also gehen wir kurz raus der grill ist
schon heiß was jetzt am besten so ein
bisschen indirekt grillen das heißt
nicht komplett über die heiße glut
[Musik]
je nach größe der süßkartoffel braucht
jetzt etwa 25 bis 30 minuten immer mal
wenden auch mal schauen dass die schale
außen nicht verbrennt und so lange kann
ich die marinade schon mal machen also
hier für die zitrone auspressen
die orange auspressen und wenn ihr keine
frische orange habt einfach orangensaft
benutzen
ich stellte mir oben so den zipfel weg
dann kann man die zitrusfrüchte nämlich
besser auspressen
ich glaube limette wäre schon mal besser
gewesen vor allem hätte ich dann etwas
limettenschale noch mit rein und eben
denn so ich glaube ich schraube schreibt
auch so in den block 1
jetzt harrys damit rein zwei teelöffel
die ist je nach hersteller mal schärfer
mal weniger scharf olivenöl und salz
pfeffer
[Musik]
und verrühren
die süßkartoffeln sind fertig die
marinade dachte ich mache ich einfach so
ein bisschen warm lass dir kurz
aufkochen
so ist jetzt auch nicht so kalt und
jetzt nimmt die süßkartoffeln und taucht
sie praktisch mit der oberweite ein und
legt sie dann ab dann kann die marinade
schön einziehen und die restliche
marinade verteidigt drüber und kann
jetzt gleich noch die tomaten und das
brot fertig stellen und dann habe ich
alle drei beilagen fertig und die schale
außen die darf ruhig dunkel werden die
snb so ist und ich mit das könnte dann
praktisch schon raus le film aus dass
kartoffeln
[Musik]
die tomaten lege ich jetzt mit der
schaltfläche auf dem grill und lasse
jetzt hier für etwa vier bis fünf
minuten schon 3
[Musik]
hier haben wir jetzt die tomaten macht
dies ein perfektes und dietrich jetzt
nur um die habe ich jetzt praktisch nur
auf der schnittkante gegrillt dre sie
umgestellt sind der marinade und dann
könnt ihr die warm oder auch kalt sein
ich finde so besonders weil sie eben
noch nicht so komplett gar sind das
heißt unten so ein bisschen bissfest und
oben aber schön kann jetzt die marinade
drauf ich erinnere mich nicht nur
optisch topshop knoblauch drin
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich die brote grillen und ihr
braucht es wie gesagt eine flache
unterlage ich nehme dir einfach
gusseisen geschehen ist hat auf dem
grill eben benutzen kann
entweder nimmt es eine große gusseisen
ferne oder kleine töpfchen also kleine
fans und die sind auch süß da lege ich
jetzt rein und grill sie dann von beiden
seiten für etwa ein bis zwei minuten 34
komme ich jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen
kleiner lassen sollen dann sie sind
jetzt doch recht und werden
guck dir mein bruder mein wort aber
entschuldigung ich wollte dass es
aussieht kommt jetzt lege ich noch schön
ins gusseisen fähnchen rein also
bisschen kleiner müsste sie ausrollen
ist das nicht süß hat das wird ok piste
kleiner ausrollen kleiner und dicker
dann sind handlicher
ich habe freunde zum glück erwähnt sie
sollen handmade aussehen
doch weil ich das schön harmonisch
schöneres bewerten aber ich bin schön
hat eine struktur
ja es hat struktur dieses brot weil ich
meinen hund kann jeder
[Musik]
schaut mal her wie schön das aussehen
ich habe jetzt hier meine drei
grillrezepte also ich persönlich muss
sagen dass ich die drei so als
hauptspeise essen würde ich brauche kein
fleisch dazu wenig aber fleischliebhaber
seid dann sind das vielleicht drei tolle
beilagen die ihr zu eurem fleisch sehen
könnt super einfach in der herstellung
supereinfach vorzubereiten und vor allem
super lecker hier meine gegrillten
tomaten das brot und hier noch die
süßkartoffel was ich zum brust dazu
sagen muss ich habe es jetzt eine weile
warm gehalten im backofen
weil ich einfach nur fotografieren ja
jeden schritt und so weiter und ich
würde sagen das brot wirklich zum
schluss so kurz vorm verzehr einfach
kurz grillen vielleicht mit der
restwärme sogar und dann sofort auf
essen
perfekt also probiert die rezepte gerne
aus ich habe es ihr euch alle einzeln
angelegt in meiner app da findet ihr
alle rezepte kostenlos können sie hoch
und runter rechnen
oder wie immer auf services blog.de also
viel spaß machen einen guten appetit und
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]